there's no real way to test for your  body's appetite for Roy's is there yeah  you can check your blood work see how  [ __ ] up it is at Baseline and then you  take you know gear and then see what  happens to it or get uh ultrasounds of  your organs or whatever most people  aren't going to do that though and then  one day they have a Jammer and they  didn't know the entire time they  probably shouldn't have taken it to  begin with what's a Jammer like a heart  attack oh okay okay that's just slang  for a heart attack yeah that's like  industry phrase I've heard yeah I'm  sorry I'm late I [ __ ] got another  Jammer  it's pretty Canadian it's a word I've  ever heard for a heart attack dude how's  pop say oh I had a big Jammer this  weekend yeah  [ __ ] her at another Jammer hey uh  I just did like five lines got a [ __ ]  Jammer in the bathroom  my chest [ __ ] hurts bud